Antoine Allen: How are you doing guys?
Today we have very special guest Ms. Emelyn
Stuart of Stuart Cinema Cafe and founder of
the October Film Festival.
How are you doing today?
Evelyn Stuart: I’m doing wonderful.
How are you?
Yes, yes.
Thank you!
Antoine: You are actually our first guest.
Evelyn: What?
Antoine: Yes.
We’ve got this amazing platform on Film
Courage.
Evelyn: Wonderful.
Shout out to Film Courage.
Antoine: And we decided to have you as the
first.
Evelyn: I feel so honored.
Antoine: Yes, because the title of this series
is Put Your Money Where Your Mouth Is.
Evelyn: Whew!
All my money!
All the kids money, all the college fund,
I put everything, I went all in.
Lester Greene: She went all in.
Antoine: And this is an important series because
I believe that people want people to invest
in them.
And they have to realize you have to invest
in yourself.
Evelyn: Yes!
Antoine: So tell me your journey.
What made you get into this crazy world of
entertainment?
Evelyn: Wow!
That’s a loaded question?
Yeah, right!
So I have a real estate background.
I’m really a business person who happens
to be in the arts.
Somebody gave me a script, I read it.
I thought “Oohh, I want to help this guy
tell his story.”
I called him up and said “What do you need?”
He said “Everything.”
I had no idea what everything was.
Everything was a lot of money.
And then I produced it and it won some awards
and I thought “Wow?
If I can figure out how to monetize this,
I could do this for a lot of people.”
Antoine: So you had the passion of giving
early on.
Emelyn: Yes, I couldn’t have said that better
myself.
Antoine: So you started with a filmmaker that
needed help, it won awards because of you.
Do you still keep in contact?
Emelyn: Yes.
Antoine: What’s his name, we’ll give him
a shout out?
I guess not…
So I want to know now is you did that, what
made you want to start a festival (the October
Film Festival)?
Emelyn: Yes so I went to a lot of film festivals
as you guys have and there was just stuff
that was missing.
I felt like a lot of festivals (no offense
to anyone out there.
I love all you guys).
But some of the festivals were very political
and I felt like I wanted to start a festival
that was clean.
And by that I mean where it doesn’t matter
who is in your film.
It doesn’t matter how many followers you
have.
It’s strictly based on you being a filmmaker
who can tell a compelling story.
And so I said You know what?
I’m going to start my own film festival
where we could do that.
Where we could just give a platform and celebrate
filmmakers for being filmmakers.
Antoine: Yes, that’s great because a lot
of filmmakers out there (if you don’t know
this), a lot of those turn into a business.
They are showing three hundred films, taking
submission fees and half the time they barely
see you.
So one thing I like about the October Film
Festival is it’s very intimate and very
engaging.
Evelyn: We’re a teaching festival.
Antoine: …A teaching festival.
When you started the festival did you even
realize how many lives you had touched?
Emelyn: I had no idea.
I still can’t really wrap my head around
all of the people that I see on television
now, the awards…I mean even you guys.
Just to see all the stuff that you’ve done
and that I know you.
Sometimes I see you and I’m like “Ahh!
Look at them.
How wonderful.”
Antoine: And to my viewers, that’s how we
met.
I was a regular filmmaker, I submitted my
short film LIFE IS TOO SHORT…
Evelyn: Actually somebody told me about you.
Antoine: Yes somebody told you…and this
is all about putting your money where your
mouth is.
So a little background story is Emelyn’s
festival was at this poet day in Harlem.
I actually rented it out a few months before
and I sold it out (packed the house).
Emelyn: Multiple times.
Antoine: Multiple times and my name started
buzzing and she started hearing my name and
I got to the festival and it felt like home.
And at the big festivals you can get lost
because if you don’t have a big name for
your festival or a big publicist you literally
get lost, you never know about networking
and contacting people.
Since then we’ve been doing business and
in partnerships.
Emelyn: And that also speaks to you never
know who is watching.
Because then I looked you up and I was just
kind of following and watching before I said
not only do I want your film in the festival,
but I also want you to come and speak to filmmakers
about how you did this thing.
How did you sell out a theater multiple times
and then I’m thinking because I had never
heard of you…so how did he do that?
So I thought if he could do it, other people
can do it, we just don’t know how.
And that’s why we’re a teaching festival.
And I said “You know, we need to come and
have him talk to filmmakers about how he did
this thing.”
Antoine: That’s a lesson for filmmakers
out there, put your best foot forward all
the time because you never know who is watching.
So now you’re this business woman, you have
this festival, you help filmmakers, now you
decided…start your own theater.
Now what’s going on in that head why you
want to do this now?
Emelyn: I think that a lot of what I do, it’s
an answer to my own problem.
So I was renting space every year for the
festival and I felt like the venues were treating
us badly, considering we were spending $12,000
to $14,000 for four days to rent a space,
I felt like the venues did not understand
filmmakers and the importance of the Q&As
(some of them were rushed) and there was a
year when they turned the lights off on us
during our red carpet.
Antoine: I was there for that year.
Emelyn: Yes, he was there for that.
And it was just devastating.
Or when a movie doesn’t play and they’re
like “We’ve got to keep moving to too
bad.”
And I thought this can’t continue to happen.
I want to be able to control when we have
the festival, when the filmmakers have events,
they should be treated better and I think
what better way to do that than to start my
own theater where I can give distribution
in terms of theater runs, where I can help
filmmakers make money and monetize their talent,
grow their audience and then at the same time
not have to deal with venues who don’t understand
what we do.
When you go into a place where there is a
four wall you don’t necessarily understand
all of the issues that filmmakers have when
they are trying to show their film.
Lester: We are here at Stuart Cinema Cafe.
Antoine: So we’re here at this famous movie
theater that you started from the ground up,
tell us what are the services?
What do you provide?
Emelyn: You know it’s interesting you called
it a famous theater.
And I heard someone earlier this week refer
to it in the same way.
And I said “Why do you call it famous?”
And she said “Because you are the first
Black Latina to own a movie theater.
And have a motion picture license and all
the stuff that comes with that.
And I thought “Wow?
Some people think this is a historical first…
Lester: A movement.
Emelyn: Yes…a movement.
Antoine: And that is one of the main reasons
is we have so many theaters out there and
you don’t know what the owners look like.
This is a strong connection because there
is nothing like seeing your own self, your
own people and think “Wow!
I could do that.”
And I want to segue to my next question…there
are young females out there that want to direct,
that want to produce.
How do you balance being a woman in this man-dominated
industry?
Emelyn: Ah…yes.
I will say I had major challenges building
this place.
All the contractors and business people that
I was dealing with, they really had a hard
time listening to what I was saying.
I’m a producer so I’m always looking for
money and there is this idea that we women
do not know how to manage money, that we’re
not a good investment.
Antoine: In 2018.
Emelyn: And it’s changing, right?
It’s changing.
But that was also one of the struggles I had
when I was doing this because people really
that like I didn’t know what I was talking
about.
So I think part of it is, you’ve got to
have a lot of your own skin in the game especially
as a women, right?
Because if you are going to wait for somebody
to write you a check based on your talents
and your visions, that may not happen.
So you’ve got to figure out how to make
it happen for yourself.
I don’t need a man to validate me.
And I feel like we all have our different
strengths and weaknesses but I know what I
bring to the table.
I think that’s critical, you have to know
what you bring to the table.
If you’re coming in with your two arms swinging,
you can’t eat at that table.
So if you know what you bring to the table,
you have a much better chance of making it.
Antoine: And to the filmmakers out there,
you have to bring value.
Your talent is just not enough.
If you have talent, that’s like a bonus.
So if there is a table, you better bring the
knife, you better bring the meat, you better
bring the milk because we are in an industry
now that it just doesn’t matter how talented
you are.
Emelyn: I almost think it’s not about talent,
as much.
I mean it matters but if you take two actors
who are equally good, it’s the one with
the hustle that gets the audition.
It’s the one that is sending out the headshots,
that’s walking around the streets looking
for work.
That’s the person getting the job.
And it doesn’t mean that they are more talented,
it means they’ve got that drive.
Antoine: And that’s why this series is called
put your money where your mouth is because
the hustle is sold separate.
I’m a filmmaker, Lester is an actor, we’ve
both won multiple awards.
There are people out there that are better
than us, but what happens is we are out hustling
everybody.
Lester: I don’t know about that.
There is no one better than me.
But I work harder than them.
Antoine: So you work harder and that’s what
you’ve got to do now.
You go into meetings and they ask you how
many Instagram followers you have.
You’re like what?
It becomes a numbers game.
Also being a founder/owner, how does it feel
having kids?
What’s that balance like?
Emelyn: Wow, that’s tough.
I have also said the hardest part of being
in the business is how many times I have to
say goodbye to my children.
Just in the morning, and I travel a lot and
I’m gone a lot and it’s hard.
But I’ll say this I live in every moment
that I’m in separately.
So tonight I’m here with you, I’m in this
moment.
I’m celebrating what’s happening here.
When I go home I’m in that moment with my
children.
I am the mommy, I am the homework, I am doing
all that stuff.
Lester: Oh…so you don’t take your work
home?
Emelyn: It’s one moment at a time.
When I’m with my mom and we’re having
coffee, I’m a daughter and at that moment,
that’s what I do.
Antoine: And that’s the beautiful thing,
you have to learn to be different people.
If you’re married, you’ve got to be a
husband or wife that night.
If you own a company, you have to be a CEO
that night.
So you have to wear multiple hats and sometimes
it confusing.
But what do you do to detox?
Having all this with the detox moments?
Emelyn: I read a lot and believe it or not,
I love reading about the industry.
So a lot of times you see me posting stuff
that I learned.
I am hungry for knowledge.
And the more that I learn, the more happier
and fulfilled I feel because I think that
there are just some rooms that we’re not
going to get invited to.
Lester: But I love that you share that knowledge.
Emelyn: Absolutely.
Lester: Some people are like I’m going to
hold onto it and I don’t want anybody else
to get ahead.
You can’t get ahead that way.
Emelyn: You can’t.
Antoine: And Lester, you’re an actor.
You’re in the business.
What do you do to detox?
Lester: [Laughs] Well, usually what I like
to do is just stay home, hang out with my
partner, hang out with my dog.
Sometimes you have to actually get away from
what you do in order to actually enjoy it.
Antoine: Disconnect.
Lester: It’s almost like you shut down and
then you reboot.
Emelyn: That’s true.
Lester: And then you go back into that world.
You have to do that.
Because you’ll drive yourself crazy.
Antoine: Yes, I think everybody needs that.
I travel and get away from everything and
then I come back refreshed.
Emelyn: I text when you’re traveling about
work all the time.
Antoine: Well that’s the thing, everybody
has their priorities.
Emelyn: He was in the middle of…where were
you?
Antoine: In Dubai.
Emelyn: Were you?
I’m like texting, asking questions because
we do a lot of business together and then
I thought “Wait?
He’s in Dubai.
I shouldn’t be texting.”
Antoine: That’s called a priority list.
In this industry there are people on the priority
list that you’re going to get right back
to.
There are going to be people where you see
the text but you’re not going to get right
back to because they are not on that priority
list.
Emelyn: Oh…that’s terrible.
That’s bad.
I hope on on the top of that list everywhere.
Antione: It’s true.
Lester: You are.
You’re on our show.
Emelyn: So now someone who text me today and
who didn’t hear back from me and watches
this is going to be like…
Lester: Oh, Emelyn doesn’t think I’m top
priority.
Antoine: Listen guys, it’s not fair.
This is what it is, it happens.
Another question I wanted to ask you, doing
all this stuff, doing this business, you are
setting yourself up for your legacy.
When you are not hear anymore, what is one
thing you want people to say about you?
Emelyn: She cared.
Because I care.
I really, really, care.
Antoine: What about you Lester?
Lester: Well…I care about everybody.
I’m always looking at…
Emelyn: That’s my line!
You cannot say…you didn’t care five minutes
ago.
Lester: I just want people to realize that
I made a different.
I want people to say “Wow, Lester was a
great guy.
He helped me out.
I remember when I needed an agent and he got
me that agent.
I remember when he gave me advice on how to
start my own film.
Emelyn: And he wrote that great book.
Lester: Right, exactly.
You can get that on Amazon (‘Act Like You
Love Yourself’).
That’s why I did the book, because I wanted
to give back to the people.
I want people to get something.
I don’t want to feel like I am taking everything
for myself.
It’s not about that.
Antoine: Yeah, guys.
This was UNSCRIPTED.
Lester: …Conversations.
Emelyn: Unscripted…yes!
Lester: All this stuff that we talked about,
there was definitely no script.
Emelyn: There was definitely no script.
Antoine: So guys this is UNSCRIPTED.
Lester: Conversations.
Antoine: Antoine Allen.
Lester: Lester Greene.
Emelyn: Emelyn Stuart.
Antoine: Film Courage.